good morning John it is Monday November
4th well it may not be for you but it is
for me I just voted with a little blaze
and I got a little ballot and I filled
in the little circles and I put it in
the ballot box so that feels very much
like November 4th to me other exciting
things that happen today include my
haircut and the completion of my
bookshelves if you include one o'clock
in the morning being part of today as I
finished it last night quite late I've
decided hey I can organize my personal
home library the way I want organize my
personal home library so yeah now I get
like a bookshelves behind me the way
that you got bookshelf behind you you
know I never stopped wanting to be like
you yeah I take you on a tour of it but
it's not very interesting and I've got
this real sort of precarious setup right
now I can't really move the camera I'm
working on it
my computer is right there the one
that's recording this there's a very
slight delay between when I do something
and when the computer registers that
I've done something so if I look really
fast I can see me looking at me it's
somewhat torturous because he's always
looking away right when I look at him ah
so tomorrow I'm gonna go on a plane to
Seattle in pretty exciting and I'm gonna
see you there John I'm gonna see a lot
of nur fighters as well and I'm gonna
see Molly sweet Afton 23 birth dress
Deena will be there I think that Kaley
will be there as well so that is very
exciting so that's the last of my events
until the actual Tour de nerdfighting
begins so if you're nearby see al you
should probably it's gonna be pretty
awesome and then John goes on without me
the next day the 29th ill be at Midland
Park and then on October 30th there's a
final Paper Towns tour Halloween special
and you will definitely want to be there
for that one if you're anywhere in the
entire state of western United States
anywhere in the entire western United
States you want to be there except I
won't be there unfortunately I will be
cleaning my house so that I can get my
security deposit back which doesn't
sound like as much fun as the
nerdfighter party but shortly thereafter
the John and Hank green along with the
Catherine tour de nerdfighting will
begin in Plano Texas on November the
second Andy
would it be so awesome oh come buddy
with us please excuse the complete
change of light quality in this room it
is now nighttime but I haven't finished
the video yet so we'll be gone it's been
a while since we selected a warming book
club book and I think that we're ready
for the next one
Paper Towns at the new blurbing book
club book do you have to try and capture
the essence of Paper Towns in ten words
or less make a blurb that John Green
would be proud to put on the back of his
book I don't know if we can work that I
want the publisher but that would be
pretty cool to get a nerd federber in
the back of the book that is all I have
today I have to say that early voting
was really really easy and if you are a
voting age and haven't got your absentee
balloting yet just go vote there's like
no line and you don't have to do it on a
specific day I don't know if they have
it in your state the same way that we do
on ours but I just call their Elections
Office a noise like an aye vote and they
were like yeah you can vote and I was
like I'm gonna come vote and they were
like oh oh I mean I couldn't have
technically voted on November 4th cuz
I'm gonna be in Indianapolis but you're
gonna need an excuse anymore it
completely is the minutes possibility
that something Bad's gonna happen on
November 4th American gonna get the
polling place anyway John I will see you
what see ya tomorrow